york governor andrew cuomo is in the
news again this time for insinuating
that
unvaccinated people could kill their
relatives
it's after he himself was accused of
allowing kobe to spread in care homes
with the state's high number of deaths
now revealed
maybe you will get a long-haul syndrome
that we're not really
sure what it is yet but a lingering
consequence of covet
or maybe you go home and kiss your
grandmother and wind up killing your
grandmother
that is a viewer grandmother survived
coleman's nursing home
do you think the moment after he said
that he was internally regretting
setting himself up like that or is he
just clueless
i'll never forgive this man for making
my friend die alone in a nursing home
don't let como get near grandma
in march 2020 cuomo ordered nursing
homes
except covered positive patients you may
recall because
local hospitals were overwhelmed critics
say that decision increased the death
toll among residents
new york state has one of the highest
covert mortality rates in the u.s
with care home deaths at around 14 000.
the governor has also been accused of
hiding the true figures but he's
repeatedly insisted he won't resign
because
he doesn't see the miscount as a
cover-up
who cares 33 28
died in a hospital died in a nursing
home
they died tracy elven an advocate for
those in nursing homes and whose
father died in a care facility in long
island thinks cuomo's comments ignore
the reality of the situation
our seniors trusted us to protect them
and what do we get
we get a governor that failed us that's
arrogant
and makes these tone deaf remarks that
continues to twist the knives
that he placed in the hearts of us the
grieving family members
we had our leaders uh in the health
department the head of the nih out in
february
telling us citizens that we knew that it
was most deadly to the elderly back then
in february
so when you sign an executive order that
puts a virus that is known to be the
most
fatal to elderly people in with elderly
people
i don't want to sound dramatic but that
sounds a lot like murder
to me and we need to know why he did it
was there a monetary reason that he did
it
all of this needs to be investigated and
every time i think he might get away
with it
he opens his mouth and he buries himself
a little bit deeper
plus the fact that we have over fifteen
thousand angels on our side so never
discount the angels
you